what up todd what up theo this is uh
barrett from sulfur louisiana what's up
brother uh first of all
theo i want to say it's real [__] up
that you announced the tour schedule
and there's no dates in louisiana thank
you big time now bouncing back and forth
between l.a and nashville and you forgot
where you came from
okay show some love man i will give us
some shows alexandra
alexandria um todd i want to say uh
personally thank you so much for um
opening up the the cane store here in
sulphur
uh right after the hurricanes whenever
our area was affected by hurricane laura
and here at hurricane delta you are one
of the first companies if not the first
company
that was uh you know serving food giving
people jobs like giving people stuff to
eat man like
just giving us some semblance of life
being back to normal so
we we really appreciate that honestly uh
my question is
you've already conquered the chicken
tender game so
what's next you know i mean you got
people like like chick-fil-a
they got all the sauces y'all gonna
start messing with some new sauces
uh you're gonna start doing like bone-in
chicken uh the real question
when are we getting spicy tenders all
right so
let me know what's next in the pipeline
gang gang baby
that's a good question yeah have there
been uh is there anything kind of new on
the horizon or there have been items
oh answer his question first i'm sorry
go on no it's a great question
um but no i mean i've always believed in
doing one thing and do it better than
anybody else
and uh that's why we have raising king's
chicken our tagline is one love and i
have one love it says quality chicken
finger meals
and so if you do what you do well and
consistently do it great
your customers will come back and let me
give you a a reason
let me tell you this like it's us and
chick-fil-a are one and two in quick
service average unit volumes like
mcdonald's sales are like a million less
than mine
right it's my repetitive customers that
come back because they're gonna get that
quality every time with a smiling face
and so
if i added different things right added
spicy i've added these
one i wouldn't be as quick in the
drive-through right because the choices
go down
i wouldn't be able to cook it cook to
order like if you come through our line
we have a cook to order system
that literally goes through i have that
whole fry line set up to deliver that
quality meal right
with the best quality you can get but if
i added all these different things
bone-in chicken takes different times
i'd have hold times my quality would go
down my speed would go down
and it wouldn't be our concept our
concept is quality food spurred with
fast food speed and convenience and
adding different things and
losing focus would lose while we're
special so when you even say the choices
so you're even talking to the minutia of
the fact that somebody then at a
drive-through
is having to make choices and that's
going to take more time that's going to
take more time right wow it's
interesting i've never thought of
the time it takes not only on the time
on my side of the counter
as the as the as the company but the
time it takes the uh
like managing the time of the person
showing up without even real
without them even really realizing it
yeah i mean we're over 60 drive-through
people want to come through and they
want to get it quick right
people know their order canes box no saw
extra toast extra sauce boom sweet tea
you're out the door
or you're out through the drive-through
and so we want to keep that time to
anneal something even like
not distracting things you know that are
going on like so even we have like right
now i did this russian recovery show but
i got
you know a picture of me and snoop
helping this one restaurant out even
that makes people stop for a little bit
and go do to do maybe ask a question in
the window and then we're like hey we
need to rethink this right i want them
getting through
because i got 20 cars behind them yeah
you know wow
wow that's interesting man uh was there
now was there ever a moment along the
way where somebody's like hey man
you know you guys need to do uh
always always have always the experts
are always like hey
you know you guys really need to add a
chicken finger salad
you know the health trends on the da da
da da and the other
and when i was younger i listened a
little more because i'm like wait maybe
these people are smarter than me maybe i
know more than me and
i'm look i'm always constantly learning
but my gut said no
because if i do that chicken finger
salad chicken salad the quality is not
not really there you know it's not the
same thing it won't be craveable
yeah and they want to come back and say
that people told me but they scared me
they were like
well you're gonna get the the cancel
vote like if one person in the car
one of the parents wants it they're not
gonna go to you go somewhere else i'm
like no
if the kids are gonna push them because
they want that quality right
staying true to what i've done not
listening
i know who i am and i'm not trying to be
all things to all people right because
if you try to be that i mean you're
gonna
you're gonna not not be anything to
anybody right i want that
craveable customer we call them kaniaks
and uh
it's paid off brother yeah and i thought
it was cocaine at first man trust me
because i remember the first time i ever
did cocaine was down at lsu man and i
took a run i thought it was
performance-enhancing drug i didn't know
that it was like a drug for just
night use or whatever so i went on a run
down by blue bonnet down by the railroad
tracks dude i probably ran almost 15
miles
jesus yeah that was not good dude that
was a bad that was a not good for the
heart yeah
good for the heartbreak still sometimes
i can still feel my heart feels like it
has a
a horsehoof in it man every now and then
it gets a little trotty
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one